colin congratulations
in this final round of competition
you'll be competing against a man who
has 30 years in his industry
he's provided weapons for deadliest
warrior
ncis
stan lee's superhumans
he's a swordsmith
he's historic weapons recreation
specialist
david baker
hi dave hey colin how you doing man good
if somebody had asked me you want to
compete against dave baker i don't mean
like
no
that's a nightmare that's crazy
look here colin
in order to become our super champion
you're gonna have to defeat dave as you
forge your way through this historic
weapon
the russian cossack world war ii shashka
sabre
oh yeah
good luck
we'll see you in 30 hours
[Music]
so which side you want you know i've won
one and a half times on this forge over
here so i'm going to take this you got
it lucky number four
so in the next 30 hours i'll be building
the world war ii russian cossack shashka
sabre i've never built this weapon i've
always wanted to
normally these bladesmiths duke it out
for the chance to go back to their own
shop
this time colin's got to come to my shop
i hope there's a bit of an intimidation
factor
[Music]
not at home
and i have to make my shashka saber
better than dave baker's
so
no pressure
obviously it has to be damascus
what i'm planning on doing is making 45
layers and then i'm gonna take those
once that's all drawn out turn into
ladder damascus take that damascus and
stick it on the side of some adcrv2
and make a damascus sand mine
this is a super championship so i have
to take risks i could do a simpler blade
construction
but
is that to this level
i've managed to do a sand mine with 300
layers of damascus on either side of a
1095 core
there are risks involved in making
damascus winding up with delaminations
or cold shots that you don't find until
the time that you've hammered out an
entire blade i made a false tang and i'm
using that to set everything up
[Music]
oh god
when the blade's done i'll make sure
that i copy this tang onto that blade
and everything should just fit right up
what the hell
what
i said what the hell you already have a
quench blade
[Music]
i don't need to rush but at the same
time dave is so far ahead i want to try
to catch up
last second quench of day one
i can't tell you how i feel until
tomorrow when i get to touch it
so this is the moment of truth right i
quenched last night put it right in this
vise
i just hope it's okay
after 10 hours i've got two thirds of my
blade done and i still have two thirds
of my time left
i don't see any cracks
today i want to clean up the shoulders
of the blade so i get a super nice tight
fit
while i'm polishing the blade i see
a delamination
so i flex the blade a little bit to see
how deep it goes
pop
i blow that thing apart
literally i experience what smiths go
through in this shop when things don't
go right
and it's a humbling experience
but i come up with an idea
i will take my broken blade chop it up
throw it in the canister and draw that
out
my second blade will have elements of
the first blade throughout
i'm just hoping that crack doesn't come
along with it
the clock on the wall
it gets in your head
my goal is to not rush
just take a deep breath and make it all
come together as nice as i can make it
happen
[Music]
i have to make sure that the handle is
perfect i don't stand a chance against
dave unless this sword is just smooth
like butter in the hand i want to get
these pieces rough shaped out so i can
fit them onto the handle and know that
it's all going to work and come together
i have absolute confidence that dave
baker can still catch back up and pass
me by the end of today
[Music]
doug get the hell out of my chair let's
get to work
so i only have 10 more hours to try to
make a blade worthy of super
championship
we're not down to the wire yet but we're
close
i thought i'd be further along but the
hiccup with the first blade set me back
the super champion's up here i'm still
down here it's 10 hours enough to make
the difference
hopefully so
one of the main focuses today is to get
this blade light and fast if it's a big
weight on the end of a handle that's not
going to cut it so i have to get as much
weight and meat out of it as i can
i got to the quench last night so i'm a
happy camper because now i can play
catch up this afternoon
i'm planning on doing a really deep etch
since i made this damascus from other
pieces of damascus this pattern could be
stunning it could be really unique i
don't know
a lot going on
looks really cool
[Music]
working with dave baker it's really
awesome and no matter what happens he
has all of my respect
whoop
it's so much fun when you're done there
you go man
gentlemen
welcome to the kill test
i will take your weapon deliver some
killing blows
on this big carcass
kanye are first you ready for this yes
sir let's do this
[Music]
nice
[Music]
good job
colin
well done sir
thank you
the balance is very wieldable
every cut with your edge cuts deep
overall sir
your shashka
will kill
thank you
all right brother are you ready
oh do that voodoo that you do so well
doug
[Music]
[Music]
the handle is spot-on
it's perfect fit for my hand
the balance of this is very wieldable
your weapon sir for this test
will kill
thank you doug
all right bladesmiths
this is our combination durability
sharpness test i'm going to start by
bashing into these pots then i'm going
to take what's left of your sword and
try to cut into the sheepskin
colin you're up first you ready let's do
it
[Music]
[Music]
well colin
there's
just about no edge damage on this thing
your handle it's a little long for my
taste that being said though it is
comfortable and all in all your blade is
still nice and straight
really well done
thank you
dave you're up are you ready
i thought you might be
well dave first off
it's all in one piece
[Laughter]
your handle
is perfectly dimensioned
it held up really well nice job thank
you sir
dave colin
welcome your final test
i'm going to take your swords and beat
them into this bamboo and post
then i'm going to strike at these
attacking dummies in leather vests
super champion time colin you ready yes
sir all right let's do it
oh
nice job kyle
i like this sword
you still got an edge
and that's some pretty abusive testing
there yeah yeah
everything's still tight everything's
still sharp
nice job
thank you
yeah yeah hulk smash go
oh
[Music]
little problem dave yeah oh yeah that
sucker's got quite a bend to it
steel's looks great though for the most
part still has an edge
but
definitely took some deflection the
other way
colin dave the judges have completed
their deliberation
colin
you are forged in fire super champion
good job brother
well done man
dave
you had a great handle your blade took a
couple of warps
i have to ask you to please surrender
your blade and leave the forge
i am happy to
gentlemen
colin's a wonderful competitor i am so
impressed with his work
biggest piece of advice i can give
anybody doing one of these challenges is
don't worry about that clock it's just a
distraction
just do your work play your game and
build the weapon you know you can build
colin
damn it look at what you've done you are
a forged and fire super champion
defeating historic weapons recreation
specialist david baker
as a super champ i just want to say
don't be afraid
courage isn't the absence of fear it's
doing something in spite of fear
i'm a super champ and i wouldn't be here
without my friends without my family
without god
anyway
super champ
got a super champ
gonna feel uh
feels good
you